made a comeback and this is like his
special skill so well we'll see what
happens and uh pragananda has kicked off
and he's moved the queen pawn to move
two squares forward yup so one d4 to
start this game when they met last month
it was colours reversed magnus actually
had white there and uh he lost
eventually and magnus does he know the
game has started he does
he brings his knight out so very
standard stuff pregnant just trying to
occupy the center with pawns here so
magnus what's he going to adopt as a
strategy in the opening okay he creates
the fianchetto is he going to go for the
grunfeld defense a really
counter-attacking opening but very
direct or is he going to play uh maybe
okay he does go for the grandfather's
gonna say the king's indian defense just
allowing white to take the whole center
that's also equally risky and we see a
trade of pawns knights also leaving the
board wow and uh moving all over the
place here yeah these two players big
experts in this opening i think 2010 and
he said he hates the grenfell defense
there's too much to memorize too much to
learn and uh if you look at the center
of the board as well white has the pawns
there occupying a lot of space black has
to chip away at uh those white pawns
from the side from afar using the two
bishops and okay eventually black does
castle the king yeah no i i i do like to
play a bit sicilian i'm trying to
experiment with that but i'm not very
good at it but i'm just wondering about
this one because in my experience you
talked about castling and if you cast a
bit late it's kind of like and i never
get to do it magnus he's really being
greedy look at that black queen she's
offside wow not really doing too much
she's out in siberia somewhere just kind
of honored her own adventure but she has
grabbed one pawn in the process so
actually prague he's being ambitious
he's sacrificed to porno uh look at this
pushing pawns in the center he's gaining
space uh meanwhile i don't like the fact
that black's queen is stuck out there on
her own there's a big risk of her
firstly getting trapped and secondly
she's gonna have to lose a lot of time
kind of rejoining the rest of her pieces
later on she's going to have to retreat
at least twice so a really clever
opening choice here from pragnanda and
after this trade
white gets the bishop pair and wow okay
he actually captures back with the pawn
here pregnant look at those pawns now on
the f-file that doubled magnus is least
comfortable when he's being attacked
we've seen him lose a few games on the
tour when the black king comes under
fire or when his opponent is pushing
everything forward
so he's definitely playing against the
playing against the man not only against
the board when you're an adult you can
actually understand the strategies much
better that's true and you can
understand how chess is the language uh
okay this move i'm not a huge fan let's
jump into the position to show uh what
pregnant's thinking is behind just
pushing his queen forward only one
square um on the last turn this pawn was
actually under fire from the bishop and
by the queen so it's attacked twice only
defended once by white's rook that's why
prague has lifted his queen up to just
add extra protection to this pawn
however white's whole plan the whole
reason he's a pawn down is because he
wants to push everything forward so to
me the most natural would have been to
push this pawn forward maybe create this
nice little pawn chain and actually
magnus has just stopped that um just but
just before this uh
before we go into this move another plan
for white to push this pawn forward and
then the central pawn and if for example
blacker just wasted time magnus of
course not doing this then suddenly
white obtains just the strongest pawns
you will ever see only really two
choices here either you remove that
black pawn from the board because it's
just
a thorn in your side or you push pawns
but he finds a third option prague
sliding his queen across maybe this was
his idea all along but magnus making a
face surprised by that one but white
bishops have the potential to control
both sides of the board and okay
he does go for the messier option yeah
the more ambitious option but nice gear
yes yeah and uh
i would assume that the pragnanda has
actually and he has in fact attacked the
queen with his rook and then you have to
study chess i guess for five hours yeah
and uh okay meanwhile as predicted this
trade of pawns both queens getting a bit
greedy there and grabbing the opponent's
pawns i mean chess players in general
are quite nocturnal but you definitely
have to um plan for that and as yuman
says acclimatize okay this move
very surprising i must admit from magnus
he's brought his knight out the knight
was attacked by the white queen
but this knight can be captured in some
scenarios by white's dark square bishop
also it's a bit loose yes it's defended
by a pawn right now but that black pawn
defending the black knight
is under fire itself here after a
recapture suddenly the rooks are looking
at each other and after a rook trade and
uh i think white's queen would just be
too far away here and it's all about the
dark squares black's queen could start
sneaking towards the white king lifting
his king up the board just to protect
the pawns around it and actually he has
done just that but if black keeps the
pawn the advantage will grow and grow
with every move so there we go okay he
does indeed just put his pawn on a
square it's protected so the black queen
black bishop really keeping that pawn
under their gaze and here we go prague's
idea is to just push in the center he
should have done this i feel maybe five
ten moves ago but better late than never
and uh if the white e pawn steps forward
now uh it will attack the black queen it
will cut the connection with the black
queen as well
and the bishop to that very far advanced
black pawn to help organizations like
unicef do their job the best is to
donate
actually uh and to buy the twinkiewinky
suit
for a lot of money that's the best way
so it is about donating and of course
also about uh chess chess community
coming together and moves coming out
yeah moves coming out and we've just
seen what we call on passant so black's
pawn advancing two squares but white was
able to capture it as if it just moved
one square um so yeah that's one
consequence and the fans okay and magnus
has played it it was good that was good
yeah no matter where you put the black
queen now this pawn is going to drop off
this has actually happened this is the
current position black gives a check but
this is easily blocked by white's rook
and again problems with the queen it's
almost out of squares you only have is
it one safe square here okay he's gone
back to the only safe square and now
this pawn is indeed dropping note how
the black rooks want to defend this pawn
but the white bishop has controlled this
key square pragnanda's position
and uh he's turned it around in my
opinion
because his bishop is better than the
black's bishop and this is what counts
when it comes to opposite color bishops
but magnus he's being resourceful as
ever you know he's really trying to
delay pragnando winning the pawn look at
this last move by uh by pragnanda he is
fearless this teenager um there's
actually a pin on the second row now and
we've talked about this in the past
rooks on the second row for black that's
where they want to be there's normally
targets there's pawns there's kings to
look at but he doesn't care he just
steps forward with his king leading from
the front and this king now is off the
second rank so this rook is once again
released from the pin and the threat is
renewed of taking this pawn and he's not
scared of advancing his king because at
the moment at least temporarily there
are no attacking pieces around it three
wins with the black pieces pregnant okay
he does retreat i was going to say is he
going to be ambitious maybe move that
bishop into the black half of the board
ambitious in this game yes and talking
of ambitious wow i know actually there's
a cunning trap uh behind this pawn move
it looks like black's just giving up a
pawn for free but let's keep an eye on
the players we might see a reaction
they're low on time as well this pawn is
poisoned white should not get greedy and
take it if you take this pawn you've
actually walked okay firstly too far
forward but onto the same rank as your
queen so the queen and king are actually
lined up and black can play an amazing
move now he can break this bishop out of
its cage he can capture this pawn in the
center of the board because suddenly if
the bishop is taken then the black rook
slides back and this is what we call a
pin kind of a skewer as well
the white queen has to give herself up
just for a rook so prague he doesn't put
his king and queen on this vulnerable
rank he retreats that king and uh yeah
really well spotted there from the
teenager once again spotting all the
danger and uh planting his king
backwards and okay a couple of quick
moves the black rook trying to join the
second rank remember we talked about it
that's where the king is but pragnando
is saying no i'm blocking you out and
now he's lining up against the black
king both kings under heavy fire and uh
blacks
king sidesteps as well play bishop takes
bourne because the second rook will come
down to the second row and join in the
attack and things are just really going
from bad to worse i think for pragnanda
i think it's about the clock we
mentioned the time trouble um yes he's
super sharp yes he spots tactics very
quickly but he's just spent too long and
he's in big big trouble now and the
formula of checks captures and threats
then he will find it he doesn't he
doesn't find it
and i think sometimes talk at the bar
yeah top players they're too busy
calculating i've been guilty of this
myself many times we calculate calculate
calculate but we forget to go for the
simple as yomanka mentions we forget to
look for checks sometimes or captures or
threats we just rule them out because
maybe they weren't good on the previous
few moves
so that's why you have to remind
yourself check capture threat every turn
he's attacking the white bishop with the
black queen now from the side but
pregnant okay he backs that bishop up
with his pawn
i think he could have moved that bishop
maybe safely but okay we see a check now
on the diagonal whoa
yeah again the white king just in too
much trouble pregnant no time and he's
on the defensive side it's impossible to
defend when you have 20 seconds left and
now the now the black queen comes into
the e3 square and it's uh virtually game
over the queen is going to plonk herself
on the g3 square give the white king a
check and uh nearly
quite a few of white's pawns will fall i
mean as you mentioned ivanka you can
give a check with the black queen first
but the dark square bishop does join
that party also remember the rook at the
top of the board
if it can somehow dislodge that bishop
it's just going to be game over so
a sad move from pragnanda when he just
has to move his king around the board
using your rooks yeah and
i praise that king march up the board
but i think pregnant is not consistent
just not finding the right square for
his king and now he's just wasted too
much time with it two pawns up now and
black has the attack
so finally the tension is broken on the
second rank we do eventually see this
rook trade but that rook is replaced by
a very strong pawn
and i think pragnanda is going to give
up any moment
the black root can actually capture the
white bishop i think that's game over
instantly
there's maybe more simple ways to win
the black rook is the only piece left
that needs to join in and that will be
it pregnant on the brink of defeat
magnus yeah ruthless and here it came
down all to that white king you
mentioned it yeah 20 30 moves ago and uh
that's why we got to look for patterns
if your opponent's king is loose
okay wow
magnus there
sitting back because he missed that his
pawn could simply be captured he's still
winning though surely um he forgot that
he the white rook now covers the second
rank he thought he was giving checkmate
next move with the black queen
he just needs to calm himself and as
soon as the black rook joins in yeah
it's game over
still
he was lucky if he made a blunder a
hallucination and it didn't affect
anything and look at that
shaking his head and smiling at the same
time it's a what i call a happy accident
those are very rare in chess i mean if
you make a bad move that's usually uh
very bad news it's more common than you
think yeah yeah you know
um
this is a skewer the white queen is now
just
has to give itself up for this black
brook yeah like defended by its bishop
and
okay even more brutal magnus is going to
take some pawns first next move the
black bishop is going to retreat with a
deadly check and there we go we have a
result pregnant giving up oh and
pregnant he just logs off